Lei ha già preso la sua decisione su di
te ed è molto probabile che tu abbia
interpretato male ogni segnale che ti ha
mandato. Non perché ti manchi
l'intelligenza,
non perché tu sia distratto,
ma perché nessuno ti ha mai insegnato
come l'attrazione femminile si esprime
concretamente nel comportamento.
Il divario tra ciò che lei comunica e
ciò che tu percepisci ha plasmato molte
più esperienze di quanto tu abbia mai
potuto immaginare.
Restate con me, nei prossimi minuti vi
mostrerò otto specifici schemi
comportamentali che rivelano una reale
attrazione per una donna, anche quando
il suo comportamento esteriore
suggerisce il contrario.
Inoltre vi spiegherò il motivo
psicologico per cui gli uomini che
mettono più in discussione il proprio
fascino sono spesso proprio quelli che
generano l'attrazione più profonda. Ma
prima ho bisogno che tu risponda
onestamente a una domanda.
Ti è mai capitato di ripensare a una
conversazione e di non riuscire a capire
se lei fosse interessata o semplicemente
gentile?
Ti sei mai convinto di non aver
interpretato correttamente quello che ti
sembrava un segnale per poi chiederti in
seguito se ti fossi sbagliato?
Ti è mai venuto in mente in silenzio che
forse non sono una persona che attira
questo tipo di attenzioni?
Se tutto ciò vi suona familiare, fate un
respiro profondo,
perché quello che state per ascoltare
potrebbe cambiare completamente la
vostra prospettiva su anni di
interazioni che avete liquidato come
insignificanti.
Ecco cosa continua a confermare la
neuroscienza sociale.
Gli uomini che mettono più a dura prova
il proprio valore vengono spesso
percepiti dalle donne come più
consapevoli di sé a livello emotivo, più
riflessivi e più autenticamente radicati
rispetto agli uomini che non si pongono
mai domande, non per via del loro
livello di sicurezza in se stessi, ma
per via di qualcosa che i ricercatori
definiscono presenza.
Analizzeremo nel dettaglio cosa
significa, ma prima, se questo canale è
nuovo per te, iscriviti subito.
Psicologia femminile è nato per offrire
agli uomini una reale comprensione di
come funzionano l'attrazione, la
connessione e le emozioni femminili. Non
perderti i prossimi episodi. Ecco un
aspetto che la maggior parte delle
conversazioni sugli appuntamenti
tralascia completamente.
Uomini e donne elaborano l'attrazione
attraverso lo stesso meccanismo.
Per gli uomini tende a nascere come un
singolo impulso diretto. Vedi qualcuno,
l'interesse si attiva, la spinta è
immediata.
Per le donne invece si sviluppa
attraverso un'osservazione stratificata.
Prima ancora di prendere una decisione
consapevole, lei sta già percependo la
tua energia. Si sta chiedendo a livello
inconscio: "Vale la pena aprirsi a
questa persona?"
non dichiara apertamente il suo
interesse, lo codifica
in piccoli segnali ripetibili che la
maggior parte degli uomini ignora o non
nota affatto. Ecco cosa faremo.
Vi illustrerò otto segnali
inequivocabili che indicano che una
donna vi trova davvero attraenti, anche
quando si comporta come se non lo fosse.
Analizzateli uno per uno con onestà.
Non per ego, non per insicurezza,
ma con chiara consapevolezza.
E prestate attenzione a una cosa.
Intorno al quinto segnale, la maggior
parte degli uomini sperimenta un
riconoscimento interiore, una sorta di
cambiamento.
Seguite il mio ragionamento e vedete se
succede anche a voi. Iniziamo.
Primo segnale, lo sguardo prolungato.
Vi trovate in un luogo qualunque, una
palestra, un evento professionale, una
libreria. I vostri occhi incontrano i
suoi e invece del breve e automatico
distogliere lo sguardo che si scambiano
gli sconosciuti,
lei mantiene quel contatto visivo per
una frazione di secondo in più del
previsto.
Poi distoglie lo sguardo.
La maggior parte degli uomini in quel
momento giunge alla conclusione:
niente.
Dal punto di vista neurologico però
quella pausa è significativa.
Il contatto visivo prolungato attiva il
sistema limbico, il centro di
elaborazione emotiva del cervello,
aumenta la frequenza cardiaca, acuisce
la consapevolezza sensoriale e segnala
che ci siamo accorti di essere una
persona degna di attenzione.
Semplicemente non manteniamo il contatto
visivo con persone che non suscitano in
noi alcuna reazione.
Il sistema nervoso non investe quel
livello di elaborazione in stimoli
neutri. Ecco cosa quasi certamente ti è
sfuggito. Lei si volta indietro. Quel
secondo sguardo non è involontario.
Pensa al tuo comportamento.
Quando qualcosa non ti interessa, non ci
torni sopra. Quando invece ti interessa,
controlli due volte per confermare la
tua impressione,
lei sta facendo esattamente la stessa
cosa. Il primo sguardo è dettato dalla
curiosità, il secondo è una scelta
consapevole.
In quel momento la calma e la fermezza
contano più di qualsiasi tecnica.
Un lento e pacato ritorno del suo
sguardo. Non uno sguardo duro, non un
immediato distogliere lo sguardo.
Segnala una persona pienamente a suo
agio con se stessa.
Se ti è capitato, non sei una persona
che passa inosservata. Seguitemi
perché il terzo segnale è quello che gli
uomini tendono a trascurare più spesso e
una volta che lo avrete riconosciuto
inizierete a notarlo praticamente in
ogni ambiente in cui entrerete.
Secondo segnale, lei crea prossimità.
Esiste un principio nella psicologia
comportamentale chiamato motivazione
all'avvicinamento.
La spinta ad avvicinarsi fisicamente a
fonti di valore percepito.
Si manifesta con uno schema che è facile
ignorare quando non si sa cosa si sta
osservando.
Ti trovi in una stanza, lei arriva senza
un motivo apparente, si avvicina alla
tua zona oppure si unisce a un gruppo di
cui fai già parte.
o si siede vicino a te quando c'erano
chiaramente altre opzioni.
Non è una coincidenza.
Le donne raramente prendono l'iniziativa
in modo diretto, ma sono
straordinariamente abili nel creare le
condizioni per la connessione.
La vicinanza è la sua versione di una
mossa d'apertura.
La ricerca su quello che gli psicologi
chiamano l'effetto di mera esposizione
lo conferma.
La vicinanza fisica, se ripetuta, crea
associazioni positive autentiche a
livello neurologico.
Si sta deliberatamente spostando nel tuo
raggio di percezione.
Ho affrontato questo problema con uomini
che erano completamente ciechi di fronte
a questo schema.
Uno di loro, sulla sessantina mi
raccontò che la stessa donna nel suo bar
di quartiere aveva scelto il tavolo
accanto al suo per ben tre volte
nell'arco diverse settimane. Lui lo
attribuiva alla mancanza di spazio.
Non era così. Una volta che smise di
filtrare quei momenti e iniziò a
rispondere con una presenza serena e
tranquilla, tutto cambiò. La
consapevolezza crea opportunità. La
prossimità non è mai priva di
significato.
Segnale 3. La stanza si riorganizza
quando parli.
Hai mai notato che una conversazione a
margine svanisce nel momento in cui
inizia a parlare?
Hai mai visto persone girarsi
fisicamente verso di te senza alcuna
apparente motivazione?
Si tratta di una presenza che opera in
uno spazio sociale. Gli psicologi la
descrivono attraverso il concetto di
gravità dello status, il modo in cui
certi individui generano una
riorganizzazione comportamentale nelle
persone che li circondano senza alcuno
sforzo cosciente.
Quando qualcuno viene percepito come
psicologicamente equilibrato e
internamente stabile, l'attenzione lo
segue come naturale conseguenza.
Questo effetto si intensifica con l'età.
La giovinezza attira l'attenzione
attraverso la novità e l'energia.
La maturità la attira attraverso la
calma e la profondità.
Non c'è bisogno di essere la persona più
rumorosa in una stanza,
bisogna essere la più radicata.
Provate questo. Lasciate che il silenzio
esista prima di rispondere.
Abbassate leggermente il tono della
voce.
Parlate a un ritmo che comunichi che
siete già arrivati, non a un ritmo che
dica che state ancora cercando di
guadagnarvi il vostro posto.
Se avete mai sentito una silenziosa
attenzione raccogliersi intorno a voi
senza alcuno sforzo, sapete già cosa si
prova ad essere veramente presenti.
Se questo ti è utile, iscriviti subito a
Feminine Psychology.
Ogni settimana approfondiamo la vera
scienza dell'attrazione, dell'energia
maschile e dell'intelligenza emotiva.
Non perderti i prossimi articoli,
soprattutto quelli sui segnali 5 e 7.
Segnale numero 4. Il suo linguaggio del
corpo segue il tuo. Esiste un livello di
comunicazione che opera interamente al
di sotto del linguaggio parlato, un
intero sistema di microaggiustamenti
e sincronia posturale che gli psicologi
chiamano rispecchiamento
comportamentale.
Quando qualcuno si sente sinceramente
attratto da un'altra persona, il suo
sistema nervoso inizia ad allinearsi
inconsciamente con i ritmi fisici di
quella persona.
Cambiate postura,
un attimo dopo anche lei fa lo stesso.
Il ritmo del vostro discorso rallenta,
la sua cadenza si adegua. portate una
mano al viso.
Pochi secondi dopo fa lo stesso anche
lei. Non si tratta di imitazione, è un
processo neurologico.
I neuroni specchio, cellule cerebrali
specializzate che si attivano durante
l'osservazione di persone con cui
sentiamo un legame emotivo, generano
automaticamente questa sincronia.
Quando il suo corpo inizia a
rispecchiare il tuo, il suo sistema
nervoso sta comunicando qualcosa che non
ha ancora espresso verbalmente.
Mi sento al sicuro qui. E per le donne
in particolare la sicurezza non è
semplicemente una preferenza, ma il
prerequisito per un desiderio autentico.
Prova questo. Introduci un piccolo e
naturale cambiamento di postura durante
una conversazione e osserva
semplicemente se si riflette nel suo
linguaggio del corpo nei momenti
successivi.
Non forzarlo,
non cercarlo in modo troppo deliberato,
semplicemente notalo. L'attrazione si
sviluppa silenziosamente,
si sincronizza prima ancora di parlare.
Segnale numero 5. Lei descrive la tua
energia, non il tuo aspetto.
Quando qualcuno ti dice che hai un
aspetto impeccabile, si tratta di
un'osservazione superficiale elaborata
rapidamente e quasi automaticamente nei
primi secondi della percezione.
I complimenti che rivelano una vera
attrazione sono quelli che riguardano la
tua energia, non il tuo aspetto. Quando
una donna dice
"Mi sento sempre più serena dopo aver
parlato con te" oppure "C'è qualcosa
nella tua presenza che non riesco a
definire? Oppure
sei davvero diverso dalla maggior parte
delle persone che incontro?"
Non sta descrivendo qualcosa di visivo,
sta descrivendo la qualità del tuo stato
interiore. La ricerca in psicologia
dell'attaccamento
dimostra costantemente che la stabilità
emotiva e l'autentica sicurezza di sé
sono tra i fattori di attrazione più
forti e duraturi.
Quando una donna ti dice che in tua
presenza abbassa la guardia, sta
segnalando un cambiamento fisiologico.
La sua risposta allo stress si è
effettivamente attenuata.
Questa è l'attrazione che opera al suo
livello più fondamentale.
Ho approfondito questo concetto con un
uomo sulla cinquantina,
riflessivo, modesto, che non cercava mai
di essere al centro dell'attenzione.
Le donne della sua vita gli dicevano
spesso che era una persona piacevole con
cui stare.
Lui lo interpretava sempre come un modo
per dire insignificante.
Non lo era. Aveva sviluppato qualcosa
che la maggior parte delle persone
impiega decenni a inseguire. la capacità
di essere completamente presente senza
bisogno che l'ambiente circostante lo
confermi. Quando qualcuno descrive la
tua energia, il tuo calore, la tua
stabilità, accogli queste parole
pienamente.
Respingere un complimento sincero è la
forma più subdola di autorifiuto.
Non minimizzare,
di semplicemente
grazie, per me significa davvero molto.
La tua autostima cresce non cercando
conferme, ma imparando a smettere di
respingerle.
Segnale sei. Venite seguiti visivamente
in una stanza, sguardi ripetuti da
lontano,
valutazioni rapide seguite da un
deliberato reindirizzamento.
Occhi che tornano su di voi più di una
volta durante un incontro.
Ecco il meccanismo.
Gli esseri umani possiedono un antico
sistema percettivo progettato per
identificare e ritornare a fonti di
valore sociale.
Siamo programmati al di sotto del
pensiero razionale per notare e
registrare nuovamente gli individui che
proiettano compostezza e autorevolezza,
non per scelta, ma per riflesso
biologico. E questo non ha nulla a che
vedere con l'aspetto convenzionale.
Ha tutto a che fare con il modo in cui
abiti lo spazio in cui ti trovi. Quando
entri in un ambiente, rilassa
completamente le spalle, mantieni lo
sguardo fisso in avanti e muoviti con
calma, senza fretta. Non stai cercando
di capire cosa pensa la stanza di te,
sei semplicemente presente.
Inizia a praticare questo e potresti
notare un cambiamento discreto nel modo
in cui gli spazi reagiscono alla tua
presenza.
Segnale 7. Gli altri uomini si calibrano
intorno a te. Questo segnale opera
completamente al di fuori di qualsiasi
interazione diretta con una donna.
Eppure potrebbe avere un'influenza
maggiore sulla sua percezione rispetto a
quasi qualsiasi altra cosa in questa
lista.
Le donne osservano le dinamiche sociali
maschili con straordinaria precisione.
Il modo in cui gli altri uomini ti
trattano comunica qualcosa sul tuo
valore che nessun fascino diretto
potrebbe mai trasmettere.
Il rispetto autentico da parte di altri
uomini ha una firma riconoscibile.
Non ti interrompono mentre parli.
Cercano il tuo punto di vista su
questioni importanti.
Ti presentano calorosamente,
ti fanno dei piccoli gesti ma
percettibili.
Il comportamento competitivo è diverso.
Atteggiamenti improvvisi quando entra in
scena una donna, umorismo con una punta
di sminuimento,
tentativi di distogliere l'attenzione
del gruppo da te.
Ecco cosa hanno in comune entrambe le
reazioni.
Confermano che ti hanno notato. Il
rispetto significa che sei riconosciuto.
L'attrito significa che sei percepito
come un fattore.
Dal punto di vista della psicologia
evoluzionistica, la riprova sociale è
una delle forze più potenti
nell'attrazione.
Quando altri uomini ti trattano come una
persona la cui presenza conta, le donne
recepiscono questa valutazione ancor
prima che inizi un singolo scambio
personale. Ecco cosa distingue il vero
magnetismo dalla semplice esibizione.
Gli uomini che agiscono con autentica
sicurezza di sé non competono per la
posizione,
non hanno bisogno di farsi sentire più
forte.
Il loro modo di essere nel mondo
comunica già il loro valore.
Quando vieni messo alla prova in un
gruppo, reagisci in modo più deciso o ti
stabilizzi.
Questa risposta interiore ti dice molto
di più sulla tua presenza sociale di
qualsiasi parametro esterno.
Segnale numero 8.
Lei immagina che la tua vita sia già
impegnata.
All'inizio delle interazioni con le
donne, spesso, prima che si sviluppi una
vera profondità, potresti notare che
emergono commenti particolari.
Immagino che non ti manchino mai le
attenzioni.
Oppure
una persona come te deve essere
piuttosto impegnata
o ancora.
Faccio fatica a credere che tu sia
ancora single.
Perché questo schema continua a
ripresentarsi?
Perché porti con te quella che gli
psicologi definiscono energia da bassa
scarsità e le donne la percepiscono a un
livello che precede il pensiero
cosciente? L'energia ad alta scarsità ha
una firma inconfondibile,
eccessivo bisogno di chiarimenti,
spiegazioni eccessive sull'investimento
emotivo. Riempire ogni silenzio perché
il vuoto viene percepito come
minaccioso.
Trasmette un'ansia fondamentale.
Non sono sicura di essere abbastanza.
L'energia a bassa scarsità è la sua
controparte, senza fretta, senza forzare
la vicinanza prima che sia meritata,
senza aggrapparsi a risultati specifici.
Ed ecco la sfumatura che la maggior
parte degli uomini non coglie. Non
servono molteplici opzioni per possedere
questa energia.
Bisogna sentirsi a proprio agio, a
livello emotivo, non per finta,
indipendentemente dal fatto che questa
particolare situazione si verifichi o
meno. Quando agisci partendo da queste
basi, le donne percepiscono come una
persona che sceglie con discernimento,
piuttosto che accettare per necessità.
La selettività percepita amplifica
l'attrazione in modi che la sicurezza
costruita a tavolino non potrà mai
eguagliare.
Chiediti direttamente
nella tua ultima interazione
significativa con una donna da cui eri
attratto, ti comportavi come qualcuno
che stava davvero valutando se fosse la
persona giusta per te o come qualcuno
che sperava che non notasse la tua
insicurezza di fondo.
Questa sola distinzione racchiude tutta
la differenza. Ora fermatevi un attimo.
Se vi riconoscete anche solo in due o
tre di questi segnali, è quasi certo che
siate molto più attraenti per le donne
di quanto la vostra convinzione
interiore vi abbia fatto credere. L'osta
è quasi mai l'aspetto fisico. L'ostacolo
è ciò che la vostra mente è stata
condizionata a ignorare. Ed è qui che
passiamo dal riconoscimento a qualcosa
di più profondo, una vera e propria
trasformazione.
Ecco uno schema che ho osservato
costantemente.
Gli uomini che sono più autenticamente
magnetici sono, paradossalmente quelli
che meno se ne rendono conto, perché
perché la maggior parte degli uomini è
stata condizionata a valutare
l'attrazione attraverso risultati
concreti.
Lei si è fatta avanti, è stata
esplicita, è seguito qualcosa di
tangibile, ma l'attrazione femminile non
si basa su risultati espliciti, si
sviluppa attraverso la sottigliezza,
impressioni accumulate, reazioni
ambientali, la qualità delle sensazioni
che una persona prova quando ti è
vicina.
Se sei stata condizionata a ignorare i
segnali sottili, potresti essere stata
circondata da un interesse genuino per
anni, senza mai riceverlo in modo chiaro
e preciso.
Lasciatemi descrivere un episodio che ho
vissuto.
un uomo, chiamiamolo David, di 58 anni,
7 anni dopo un doloroso divorzio,
si era costruito una narrazione su se
stesso. A quell'età, quel tipo di
interesse era qualcosa che suscitavano
altri uomini, non lui.
Ma quando abbiamo esaminato attentamente
le sue recenti esperienze è emerso un
quadro completamente diverso.
Una donna nella sua palestra sceglieva
sempre l'attrezzo più vicino al suo.
Un'impiegata del bar ricordava ogni
dettaglio del suo ordine e si sporgeva
in avanti quando gli parlava.
Durante un incontro di quartiere, una
donna rideva di gusto alle sue
osservazioni e tornava spesso a
chiedergli la sua opinione.
David aveva respinto ogni singolo
momento, non perché non fossero reali,
anzi, lo erano chiaramente,
ma perché la storia che si portava
dentro li filtrava automaticamente prima
che potessero essere percepiti come
segnali autentici.
Gli psicologi chiamano questo fenomeno
bias conferma,
il meccanismo per cui il cervello cerca
attivamente informazioni che confermino
le convinzioni preesistenti, scartando
inconsciamente le prove che le
contraddicono.
Se la tua convinzione di base è non
genero questo tipo di interesse, il tuo
cervello adatta la tua esperienza di
conseguenza.
Non per cattiveria, ma per efficienza.
Il lavoro che cambia davvero la tua
esperienza non riguarda miglioramenti
esterni,
riguarda l'aggiornamento della
narrazione che porti con te riguardo a
ciò che generi nelle persone intorno a
te.
La tua percezione di te stesso non è
immutabile,
è una storia e le storie possono essere
riviste attraverso l'accumulo
consapevole di prove contrarie concrete.
Ecco tre pratiche che rendono tutto ciò
tangibile.
Esercizio numero uno, la registrazione
delle prove.
Ogni sera di questa settimana annota un
momento della tua giornata che ha
contenuto un autentico segnale sociale
positivo,
uno sguardo prolungato, qualcuno che si
è avvicinato a te, uno sconosciuto che
ti ha mostrato cordialità. Non
analizzarlo,
non cercare di giustificarlo,
semplicemente registralo.
Nel corso di diverse settimane, il tuo
cervello inizierà a costruire una nuova
biblioteca di riferimento
basata su ciò che accade realmente, non
su presupposti ereditati.
Secondo esercizio, regolatevi prima di
entrare. Prima di qualsiasi situazione
sociale, fate tre respiri lenti e
consapevoli.
Inspirate dal naso per 4 secondi.
Trattenete il respiro per 4 secondi.
Espirate per 6 secondi. Rilassate la
mascella, abbassate le spalle
consapevolmente.
Questa singola azione sposta il vostro
sistema nervoso dalla modalità di
rilevamento delle minacce alla modalità
di connessione sociale.
Gli altri percepiscono questo
cambiamento nel vostro corpo prima
ancora che venga scambiata una sola
parola.
Il vostro stato di equilibrio è il
vostro stato più efficace.
Esercizio numero 3, ricostruisci le
prove del tuo passato.
Pensa a tre momenti specifici della tua
storia in cui una donna ha mostrato un
interesse chiaro e inequivocabile,
anche se la situazione non si è poi
evoluta. Scrivili con quanti più
dettagli possibili.
Poi chiediti com'ero in quei momenti?
Meno autocritico,
più a mio agio in modo naturale? Non
analizzavo ogni segnale alla ricerca di
segni di fallimento.
Quella versione di te non è scomparsa.
Era sepolta sotto un accumulo di dubbi
su te stessa e anni di domande senza
risposta.
Quella versione, quella che era
semplicemente presente senza una
costante sorveglianza interiore è
proprio quella a cui le donne rispondono
in modo più naturale e potente. Ora
vorrei ricondurre tutto a un punto
essenziale perché c'è un ultimo
cambiamento interno che rende tutto
questo funzionale anziché meramente
concettuale.
Quando smetti davvero di chiederti "Lei
mi trova attraente"? Qualcosa di
straordinario si apre. Inizi
naturalmente a porti una domanda
completamente diversa.
È una persona che voglio davvero nella
mia vita? Condivide i miei veri valori?
Questa transizione ristruttura
completamente la tua energia nelle
situazioni sociali.
Quando un uomo valuta veramente un'altra
persona, invece di analizzare
silenziosamente se stesso alla ricerca
di inadeguatezza, la sua presenza cambia
completamente.
L'urgenza si dissolve non per sforzo, ma
per un autentico reindirizzamento
dell'attenzione.
E questa qualità di curiosità radicata,
un uomo presente senza essere avido di
approvazione crea un'apertura verso cui
l'energia femminile è quasi
istintivamente attratta. Immaginate la
scena in modo concreto. Siete a un
evento sociale, non state recitando una
parte, non state scrutando i volti in
cerca di approvazione, siete
genuinamente presenti, cordiali, senza
fretta, coinvolti. Avete una vera
conversazione invece di cercare di
intercettare tutti i presenti. Vi
allontanate quando vi sentite pronti,
non quando avete finalmente raccolto
abbastanza rassicurazioni da
giustificare la vostra partenza.
Da qualche parte, dall'altra parte della
stanza una donna se ne accorge,
non la tua strategia, non la tua frase
d'apertura, la quiete, il fatto che tu
non stia inseguendo nulla, il modo in
cui gli altri si orientano naturalmente
verso di te e con esattamente quel tipo
di tranquilla e deliberata
intenzionalità che abbiamo descritto
durante tutta questa conversazione si
posiziona più vicino a te. Ecco come si
manifesta davvero l'attrazione senza
miti.
Non una formula,
non una grande performance,
una qualità di presenza che spinge le
persone ad avvicinarsi perché qualcosa
dentro di loro riconosce un'autenticità.
Prima di concludere, riflettete
onestamente su una domanda. Se credeste
davvero, non in teoria, ma come una
realtà vissuta nel vostro corpo, di
essere una persona che le donne trovano
profondamente attraente, cosa fareste di
diverso domani? Soffermereste lo sguardo
mezzo secondo in più? Parlereste con
meno fretta e più autorevolezza?
Smettereste di analizzare ogni
interazione a posteriori alla ricerca di
prove di un fallimento?
Qualunque sia la tua risposta, quel
cambiamento inizia ora. L'attrazione non
è qualcosa che insegui lungo un
corridoio sperando di afferrarla.
Si irradia da ciò che sei quando smetti
di preoccuparti dell'impressione che gli
altri hanno di te.
Quando incarni questo stato d'animo con
fermezza, calma e senza scuse, non hai
bisogno di chiederti a che punto sei.
Semplicemente rimani lì e la donna
giusta percepirà la differenza
prima ancora che tu abbia pronunciato
una sola parola. Se questa conversazione
ha davvero cambiato qualcosa per te,
sostieni Feminine Psychology mettendo un
mi piace a questo video, non per
l'algoritmo, ma come segnale per te
stessa che stai scegliendo una nuova
consapevolezza per il futuro. Iscriviti
se non l'hai ancora fatto. Ogni
settimana approfondiamo la psicologia
dell'attrazione, la presenza maschile e
cosa serve per costruire quel tipo di
energia che attrae le persone in modo
naturale. Lascia un commento qui sotto e
dimmi
quale degli otto segnali ti ha colpito
di più. È stato lo sguardo prolungato?
Il modo in cui le stanze si
riorganizzano quando parli?
O il segnale numero 8.
Le donne che danno per scontato che la
tua vita sia già piena.
Leggo ogni commento perché la tua
riflessione potrebbe essere esattamente
ciò di cui un altro uomo ha bisogno
oggi. Ci vediamo al prossimo video.